nella gt ragazzi e benvenuti ove sono
video sono fa vigenti ed oggi siamo
finalmente su tre daud ragazzi veramente
non so se lo ricordate la cavavo
giocando alla demo tipo non so quanto
tempo fa perché sa ragazzi che mi ha
sorpreso è che è anche in italia non c'è
stata da me l'aspettavo proprio
inserisce il nome dello slot si selphy
chi può perfetto allora ok ci siamo
ragazzi siamo partiti non vedo l'ora di
vedere se il diavolo hanno fatto non
aver paura di aprire le porte giuro se
per caso trovo qualcosa dietro le porte
ma avevo per caso mi che azzurro che
vengo a cercare chi ha scritto sta fra
te lo giuro
rihanna seguono forse non eri anno mi
sto sbagliando non lo so non ne sono
sicuro le gambe erano ragazzi una
canzone profondissima un testo così
bello non avevo mai sentito simbolo
stian canio che è che sarah appena
partiti perfetto chi cazzo è questa
quelli dietro ci stanno ammazzando zia
non so se ne sta accorgendo prova bene
[Musica]
ragazzi che cazzo di gioco horror è
questo un atmosfera horror che ti entra
proprio nelle vecchie cose canzone è
fantastico cioè il mio dio perché questa
sia la strada giusta prof
che però a questa prof penso di sì ma
qualcosa simile che la strada si è
diventato lo stilista è stata
l'improvvisa e bellissimo ragazzi perché
tipo in italia non c'è sta cosa non me
la sarei mai aspettata casa che è
successo capisce cos'è calmi però ha
amici miei non sono veri preciso va
portato il tomtom
mi dicono questa strada non è tanta gb
la prova bene è una cosa
kick ass bellissimo comunque che non
guido io quindi il problema è già
risolto
posso muovermi ma si preferì ci si possa
muovere perfetto se non siamo fermi
davanti a una strada caduta prezzi e
tutti fi selphy fantastico se veramente
un genio chi col cellulare in mano
professoressa sisca dove si assista che
cazzo di nome sica non mi aspettavo
proprio che qui ci fossero i ponti e le
cose si complicano un po in teoria
dovremmo essere non dovremmo essere
troppo lontani da casa si sta mischiano
questo scattarle la scatola fatta questa
che si fa i salti sorridi che la
mettiamo su facebook
ok perfetto a questa etica l'ho fatta io
poi tagami come facciamo ad arrivare lì
allora non lo so mica è soprattutto una
domanda ma perché cazzo ci stiamo
andando lì dove ci troviamo esattamente
non lo so è guidato to cazzo per gioco
saprai to almeno mica troppo piena ma
che me ne vado in giro io da solo perché
non è possibile la partita a carte anche
va bene ma qualsiasi cosa che cazzo poi
a quell'ora la smetta di frugare sofà e
cercando bach dove bride ragazzi stessa
non mai
questo se ne vale niente lui ma venite
qui la segale dove stai andando questo
prende iniziative
ovviamente se c'è un ponte distrutto e
cosa fanno dei degli studenti noi
prendono la strada alternativa purissima
fantastica cioè geni proprio da un'altra
parte del potere che non sono anche come
il grafico silent hill sta cosa
6 la maida tang di ok non è bellissimo
per una città c'è un motorino ragazzi ho
fatto qualcosa vi ho già ve lo dico io
io vado avanti c'è ormai ragazzi
lasciavano indietro a chi offre di
correre siamo rimasti in due neanche più
gemme dal gruppo è morto mi prendi è una
città fantasma ma dai che scoperta
fantastica valera il punto della gita di
classe che cazzo stanno facendo cioè
l'obiettivo era di visitare una città
fantasma cosa mi chiedo perché questa
città sia stata abbandonata non perché
ci sei tu che sparì minchiata cielo
aperto
perché ho sognato sin da piccolo di
poter visitare dei posti del genere
finalmente l'occasione di farlo perché è
il in guarda che la scuola enorme
c'è una sua è una scuola questa bella
verderame veramente bella c'è il mio dio
di sicuro meglio della mia è una
panchina sembra esattamente identica a
quella su cui ci si devono alla
elementare non è vero ma sai quanto
cazzo me ne può fregare non sentiamoci
la per un po sì certo abbiamo perso
tutto il gruppo c'è una città fantasma e
ci sediamo tranquillamente sulle
panchine mas massima certo non si sono
persi gli altri permesso ai ragazzi di
non vedere cosa c'è dentro venite non ho
parole io facciamo finta di non aver
visto l'ultima scena è morta mizar
popolazione del mondo e questa è buona
norma ma [ __ ] a vedi le nel
frattempo è diventata notte quello sono
ancora sulle panchine questa mi ha fatto
cagare aldo sopra meno un capolavoro
capito e stava scherzando sono l'ha
detto da un sacco non lo so magari è
scesa notte se volete entrare
forse dovremmo andare a vedere che
stanno facendo ma da e vi siete
tranquillamente sedute su una panchina a
giocare finchè non è arrivata la notte
ci mi dico ma mentalmente come state
messe è stata una specie di folle visita
al museo qualcosa del genere ma dove hai
hai hai hai hai hai iamm giu bellissimi
nomi o merda adesso dove sei cacciatori
ma andiamo a cercare gli ayane ragazzi
se siete dei dementi che c'entra tristi
posti cioè non è colpa mia è normale
perché succedono ste cose ma continuando
a cercare ayane
però non ho capito questa sta camminando
me se fosse uno zombie però è che ci sta
provando adesso professoressa stanno
chiamando al telefono ma mi sa che la
linea non prendo in si posti regala la
tizia dijon sta leggermente che cazzo
cia si ho capito il problema non è tanto
il tizio che se penso ma la tizia che
sta camminando così ma non la vede
nessuno
[Musica]
a controllo remoto delle serrande
tecnologia ragazzi che siamo avanzati in
una maniera incredibile a chiarire che
se un party credo e spero non lo so per
che cosa fa ci siamo blindati con dentro
fantastico ragazzi bene così e vero che
non ci volevo neanche entrare quando
sapeva che succedeva ste cose idiota
ragazzi ci siamo persi qua dentro
perfetto sono più se le porte obiettivo
aggiornato bentornato a scuola per il
primo giorno di scuola più o meno così
per tutti e bellissimi posti comunque
meravigliosi non è possibile aprire
questa porta ok ma io posso posso
fotografare le cose il successo patito
un film ho cliccato il tasto per il
telefono è partito film che è successo
ragazzi a privati prima il number
perfetto star sta chiamando qualcuno
franto sono io sono io sono io ringrazio
perfetto legato che caso io non ho
sentito mia facciamo finta di niente non
importa partito il telefono h passato
ragazzi se ne c'era un tizio lì davanti
prima che non non ho avuto il piacere di
conoscere ma non importa meglio per i
cani che cazzo è successo sul mare ma
c'è qualcuno ragazzi che sento
che cazzo c'e un cinghiale via terra
eccolo della belva penzola penzola un
mazzo di chiavi a se prendiamo il mazzo
di chiavi grazie
evviva che cosa ci fa un cinghiale di
280 kg qua dentro
merda sola dentro sono eto'o chiude
chiude ecco il prefetto belva di merda
vai fuori una voglia di spiegarmi come
cazzo ha fatto entrare è entrato nella
fine perfette non se ne sta andando per
lui lui lui fa può passare attraverso i
muri giustamente se talmente bello che
giurati ti farei un forno veramente ok
sì se ciò fa mica sono un genio è
sparito perché lì ho fatto la foto
praticamente credo se n'è andato bene
così ricordatevi che se perché se vi
trovate nella sua manà il contratto era
non so tipo leonio cinghiali grossi due
metri fatevi un sexy e vedete che
funziona cioè sito a posto dall amico
mio devi smetterla di scassa armi le
parti ma quanto sei bello ma com'è che
se lo guardo così a una scelta faccia ma
solo morto così è molto più bello di
prima mi dico ma la vedevi capire razza
di cinghiale shrek che non sei altro di
toglierti la mia vista perché mi stai
sul culo è perfetto così ecco bravo cosa
volevo rientrare qua dentro il cesto
bagnolet ai ragazzi si giochi è sempre
il posto migliore se io non so perché
sto anche aprendo le porte ma mi sa che
mi conviene non c'è nessuno non c'è
nessuno miracle non avrei mai detto io
io vi giuro il terrore che che casa cioè
il fantasma di prima
c'è tipo dove ma io questo lo vedo anche
senza cazzo è solo qualche no dove vai
lui cazzo se ne va per i cavoli suoi
vabbè pazienza io vado sopra c'è sempre
si è ristrutturata sarebbe veramente
[ __ ] come scuola cos'è quel costo c'è
una che cazzo non fatemi tragua dentro
però non ho capito un che c'è una se una
cos'è sta roba
una statua cazzo e so cosa hai trovato
zheng jie zheng lot energia mistica per
mano a quella questo oggetto fantastico
mi fa piacere ragazzo sto iniziando a
sentire rumori bruttissimi non fosse
normale
1 ok calmi inchiesta cosa non me
l'aspettavo effettivamente qui veloce
anche vedo merda
cos'è successo prega calmi qua dentro
però veloci però merda che chiude subito
giorgio gobbi e fazio bobby qua dentro
perché sei qui ma è normale che continua
a sentire store anche se la mente
usciamo di qua ma veloci proprio noi
siamo un finito e c'è un cazzo che pensa
già bello che che se ci fai qui senti
c'è una tizia fini no non scappare ti
prego vieni qua allora se l'unico amico
che ho trovato in mezz'ora non ti presto
la cosa perché sei mio amico dammi una
mano ti prego di farmi uscire di qua
perché se non siamo messi male
si vabbè ma se inutile cazzo di gatto
dove vai
no non di lato ad andare via che c'è una
tizia fortissima era la mia massima
aspirazione riuscire a spaventarmi così
giuro veramente mi avete reso felice per
questa roba c'è una praga buongiorno
ragazzi un rookie cos'è sta roba una
tizia salve se vuoi john kinder cereali
nel taschino se vi interessa non so
possiamo fare amicizia
non ho preparato niente sticazzi son
rotto genova genlock sneak perfetto sono
iscritte fantastiche di chi statista
scuola e mi fa piacere problema è che
c'è locale stato colpiti si ferma non
entra classe caduto in uno stato di
trance lo facevo matematica mi succedeva
pure a me alle 10 mentre la
professoressa asti sta avendo una
lezione di geografia residenti hanno
urlato ha preso a calci banche ho fatto
anch'io la disperazione quando facevo
geografia sentite però io ho trovato
delle chiavi mele fate usare per favore
soltanto che se c'è un'altra pagina
reincarnazione reincarnati c però stai
calmo
chi cazzo sei tu sento buon uomo lei è
uno scassato gli angoli occhiali per il
mal di testa
movente la cosa migliore si sentì però 6
mal di testa devia
posso battere calmo caldissimo
grandissimo nel successo mia calmi non è
neanche gridato è stato molto buono ti
ho controllato quasi tutte le stanze
romane marchio più nessuna solo non si
vedono i due fantasmi vabbè di qua si va
da qualche parte
questa porta adesso è aperta perfetto
grazie all'asse con ragazzi mi ricordo
che la demo era era completamente
diversa focali che dopo dove sei che non
ha perso lo sapevo ma rituali [ __ ]
muori strozzando ragazzino io posso
concludere con il primo episodio perché
dal prossimo mills da vedere cose strane
ma non rispondono niente sedi dove più
giù dal suo trattamento mi piace anche a
pagliari facebook e corniglia trovate la
descrizione quello serventi discreto e
ci vediamo il prossimo vivo bella
ragazza